the reason why i wanted to do this film
was michael bay the whole energy of this
movie is something different than i've
been a part of here we go
michael bay is the consummate action
director of his time
he has a very specific stylistic
approach to the way that he tells
stories and it has real stakes emotional
stakes
suspects have hijacked a red and white
ambulance diy suspect fled from the
parking
garage we meet will he's a veteran and
his wife has cancer and desperately
needs this experimental surgery that the
insurance will not cover
danny has lived in a life of criminality
and he's also needing money in a
different way and so will goes to ask
for a favor from his brother that's my
brother doesn't look like your brother
wow that is original will is adopted but
they have a real brother relationship
full of all the messiness and violence
and love he hasn't seen his brother for
a long time for the right reasons i will
do anything for you and all i'm asking
is for you to do this one little thing
for me but at the end of the day love
makes you lower your standards and now
you're here asking me for help and what
am i giving you i am giving you the
world
danny's getting what he's always wanted
which is his brother back let's go dee
don't shoot a cat plans go awry and they
find themselves hijacking an ambulance
i'm gonna need you to help us why don't
you help us i got a cop shot i gotta get
him to the hospital we don't get to see
that a lot you know we don't get to see
our female character make a decision
between her own life or others you need
to help me go help me help the cop i
also really liked this woman at the
center of a story who just doesn't take
crap from anyone get the defeat pads
right chest left ribs why right or
you're right he's right [ __ ] the power
dynamics consistently changing because
keeping the police officer alive is
their only way to not get immediately
killed by lapd do you have empty
experience combat three hours then
everything just becomes wild really
quickly i don't know what happened
he's about to die
we got an airship
we're sitting duck where we gotta move
it felt like a small independent indie
movie that we were doing in the back of
an ambulance and then i see the
humongous explosions like oh it's still
michael bay movie
working with michael bay it was just
wild from the first day i want the helo
to come in from up here he likes to do
practical shots you're driving to 80
miles an hour shooting at a helicopter
with another helicopter behind it and
i'm going
[Music]
what's happening
we're not the bad guys
we're just the guys trying to get home
i got to get back to my wife and my son
does your wife know you're all banks
michael bluff's an enthusiastic actor
who has ideas he has a real reverence
for actors i think he really respects
the process
these guys are nut jobs in two hours
they're either dead or in cuffs and it
belongs in the theater and i cannot wait
for it to be in the theater well
hopefully they leave the theater sweater
stop you hear me you're gonna hurt
someone we don't get to walk off into
the sunset
[Music]
you